how are you I'm good rich uh actually I
was gonna say how are you but I saw a
little bit ago on Twitter your
announcement of the you know NFL 100
showing the the Chris Collinsworth slide
I thought was funny
thank you I was not expecting the Bill
Belichick not just cameo but six
episodes the Belichick is that right Ian
Rapoport it is accurate all six episodes
and as somebody who has dealt with
Belichick and knows his off podium
persona and his love for the game he is
dynamite as the analyst dynamo top notch
I can't wait I mean I love that stuff
anyway
and I was gonna watch anyway but man
that is that is gonna be awesome so
congrats to you that is very cool well I
would think again I said at the top of
the show it was it's one of the it's
definitely a top five in terms of what
I've done in my career the show is
special the guests who show up who are
on the list to learn that they're on the
list is special and then they all look
at Belichick and none of them can
believe that he's on the set asking them
questions and knowing about their
careers in the minutiae of it because he
is and and and just it becomes apparent
again that he has connections to pretty
much everybody from the 50s and 60s to
the 70s 80s and then coaching against
them in the 90s and the late 80s and the
arts and the current day he is the
perfect analyst for this show perfect
awesome cool not wait I'm glad well
let's get some good stuff from you hear
what's going on with the Cowboys why are
they waiting on signing players that we
know they're gonna have to sign what's
going on
well I mean I think these things you
know don't exist in a vacuum and there's
although obviously we know Dallas is
sort of prioritizing you know they want
to do an extension for Dec we know they
at least have had conversations about
doing one for Zico though it would be
two years are really similar to Todd
Gurley we know Amari Cooper's on the
list but like let's say receiver you
know there's several other receivers who
you know we're probably going to get
paid Michael Thomas could get paid at
some point I think Julio Jones is going
to get paid so I think that one probably
hasn't get done because Omar is waiting
for the others you know the DAC deal I
mean it it's maybe a little more
concrete I would say since we know
Carson Wentz got thirty two a year but
you know a lot of times these deals get
done especially the cowboys before the
season you know rather than you know
before the season rather than before
training camp so there definitely is
time there's something they want to do
but it's not like they're on the clock
it's not like there's a deadline yet
well I we had Joe banner on in this
earlier this summer when Carson Wentz
got signed by Philadelphia and he says
that the Cowboys are habitually late to
sign players that everybody knows that
they are going to sign I mean you know
this organization inside and out as well
like what is what is their philosophy
again Rams went ahead and signed Gurley
early and and now you know the wench get
signed early what why why don't the
Cowboys do something like that
I would say they're not always late
because you look at Tyron Smith or star
left tackle locked up for like ten years
Travis Frederick same way I mean they
had several core players that they did
early DeMarcus Lawrence they did really
late and probably paid a premium for it
however he also had the suspension he
had back issues I think there was a
reason for that one so they have done
some players early when it sort of
benefits them the hard thing is going to
be you know I think there probably was a
thought or early on that you know dak
would take you know dak would take a
deal that wasn't that great and he'd
come to save some money for the like I
don't I don't think dak is taking a
hometown discount nor should he nor
should anyone I'm sorry I think it's
just a matter of everyone knows the
Cowboys priorities and they're a good
agent involved and they want to make
sure that you know they actually
maximize what they're getting well I
mean the reason why these conversations
are brought up on the outset of a season
is because you know this is how games
get affected and you know heads get
messed with
is it possible Zeke holds out is it
possibly does not show up
it is possible I have not heard a firm
decision one way or another but it is
definitely possible and I know you know
this is something he's considering the
problem is you know to think about it is
one thing fundamentally philosophically
it absolutely makes sense just like with
Melvin Gordon it it makes sense
philosophically it is another thing when
all your friends are practicing you are
not we're all talking about you and
you're getting fine $40,000 a day like
it's that is some serious stuff so I
think he's considering it but whether
he's actually going to do it we have not
found out the sin of the bling my NFL
media compadre Ian Rapoport in the Honda
insider port here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk Melvin Gordon here well how
does this play out what happens well you
know the charges similar to the Cowboys
and a lot of times do deals right before
the season you know probably mid to late
August and you talk about a possible
Philip Rivers extension if that's going
to happen I think that's probably that's
probably when it would be sorry I'm as
I'm checking my text messages as I'm
talking you see the problem with Melvin
Gordon is they actually are trying to
get something done they negotiated
negotiated in June negotiated in July it
offered him a really nice deal not quite
what he wanted but you know a really
nice deal and he's gonna take a hard
stance and hold out and we'll see if the
Chargers blink he's a running back and
it's just hard to find a lot of team
that is really really willing to pay for
that well I mean we saw what Le'Veon
Bell did and is Melvin Gordon prepared
to do something like that I mean is that
what is gonna do at this stage of his
career doesn't have the loving on Bell
cachet in terms of stats and anything
else built up like that but that's
basically it it's like if you're gonna
hold out you got to go the distance
essentially is what loving bellieve
improved
right now you know I've talked to Melvin
Gordon about this specifically he was a
big proponent of you know he is a big
proponent of kind of taking a hard
stance and making sure that not just
well they beyond agape but all the
running backs in the future so I think
Melvin Gordon supports it but it's
different when you're actually doing it
you know I think the plan is to hold out
I don't think it's you know gonna be the
kind of thing where he's sitting out the
season certainly would be stunned by
that because he's in a different
situation he's under contract that's
supposed to double was not but at the
very least at this point he is pretty
serious about it
you can Rappaport here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so what what what about the
40-something quarterbacks I just had
Sean Payton on in our number one he's
got Brees towards now on the the
official 40-plus Brady's 42 what is the
futures for these guys I mean could they
be playing out the string in 2019 what
are you what are you hearing about this
yeah I mean from what it sounds like the
mindset from these guys is is you wait
till they come to camp you see how they
are and you kind of make a decision
accordingly I think Brees has shown you
know a couple of times he's taken it
right to the end first with the
franchise tag thing then a cut was a not
last person but to pre-seasons ago are
two off seasons ago I should say when
you know he was basically a free agent
and some teams are interested and he
ended up getting a deal done with the
same to me basically take a look at them
in camp and you decide if they still you
decide if they still have it and you
know I think one thing with the Patriots
they've always redone Brady
they have not yet shown that they're
gonna do that yet and I think their
their point is basically we have you
under contract we don't know how long
it's going to be but it is Tom Brady so
I gotta think that something ends up
getting done before the season and
what's your thoughts on drunk in 2019
and that's been a hot topic on this show
and everywhere else lately
I would say I'm probably not like most
people I think everyone you know most
people I've talked to even Patriots
people have said like yeah you know we
don't know but there possibly comes back
I'm sort of not of that line of thinking
first of all he seems to have lost some
weight second of all he's enjoying life
and football is very hard and I think
you know by the end grogg it was very
hard for Gronk it was very hard and I'm
not sure he wants to be put through that
again I mean maybe you know could I see
a situation where he comes back in like
November in place two months I guess
that would probably be the only
situation I could see but even still
that's a little bit of a stretch because
how many games are you really getting
and if you're getting the Gronk that you
had last year is that even really worth
it obviously so I'm gonna ask you the
question I keep getting it at
restaurants or dinner parties and things
of that nature whenever I'm around NFL
fans which is like every two seconds why
did the NFL do nothing in regards to
Tyree kill based on your reporting and
your knowledge and talking to people why
did why did they come back me heroes be
the closest I can get to the truth and
you know the NFL doesn't come out and
sort of explain this
aside from from the statement we get the
closest I can get is they were not 100%
sure he did it and you know with the
Zeek Elliot thing I know everybody
compares him based on the interviews and
the metadata and everything they
released at the time no they were very
clear in their minds that you know it
was very clear in their minds that we
did it and I think with you know Jaron
read yesterday the Seahawks our
defensive lineman who got six games they
believed he did it
thing with Tyree kill you know the if
you listen of the entire level in the
audio from Hill and his fiance in that
Dubai Airport there's even some doubt
other over whether he did the 2014
incident let alone you know breaking his
son up son's arm which the fiance
essentially admits he didn't do I just
don't think Dan upon any actual proof
that Tyree did it
so is-is-is a player is I guess player
discipline on the table here and the
collective bargaining agreement
conversations that heated up a bit last
week and are still going on we assume
without a spotlight on it and what are
you hearing about I haven't heard
specifically that it is on the table
I would imagine at some point they would
discuss it but you know as you know like
anything that is discussed is sort of
open for trading and horsing the horse
trading I would say I would imagine that
they'll at least discuss that the
problem is do you want to make this one
of your stances when it only affects a
very very small amount of players and
those that it does affect were the ones
who unfortunately a lot of times got
themselves in trouble you know that's
kind of the issue is you want to take a
strong stance on something that affects
maybe two or three guys every year
that's kind of or maybe less that's kind
of the issue all right so last one for
you what do you think is going to be the
story of training camp 2019 David we're
getting back to work week what do you
think is going to be the the overarching
conversation coming up before the season
oh man
you know that's a great question I I
know this the ones that I will sort of
be focusing on as always is the
quarterbacks I'm fascinated by the
Giants I mean you know I probably
wouldn't the job that I wouldn't say a
hundred percent sure the Redskins are
really interesting and the Dolphins are
really interesting there's other
quarterback stuff that's kind of going
on but you know those daddles as well as
you know sort of how good mahomes is and
what carson wentz looks like i mean it's
as always the quarterbacks the ones I'm
going to be focused on and that'll kind
of be the most fun so on behalf of all
fans of Josh Rosen
and hoping he gets a chance and to prove
what he can after what happened over the
last year why are the dolphins
interesting are you telling me Fitz Fitz
magic he's gonna be given a shot to beat
out Josh Rosen after they flip tattoo
for him are you saying that that is why
the Dolphins are interesting or or did I
miss another interesting thing about the
Dolphins for you know I think that's
about right
I mean I think it has a very realistic
chance to to compete hard for the job
and maybe win it and we'll see what
happens but I do not think it's a
situation where Rosen came in and
attended the starting job they're gonna
compete one thing you know about fit in
small pockets that played very well no I
mean he's indestructible and I
understand that coaches have to have the
the outward approach and also even the
the true mean you mean it when you say
it you got to compete but please I mean
how do you not find out if Rosen's the
guy and you stick him in there in week
five week six and you I don't understand
I would not understand that I wouldn't
understand that in a million years I
wouldn't understand that unless you're
tanking for two unless but as you know
in pockets fits magic wins games too so
yeah he could he could ruin the tanking
if that was the plan I would say this if
they if Rosen does not win the job if he
isn't the better player in practice if
he isn't the better player in preseason
games then there's not much of a reason
to kind of just put him out there and
see what he has if he if it's a
competition and Fitz win then you
probably get your answer at least in the
short term and that obviously you know
it's a bad situation for the Dolphins
but at least they know that the next
year they're probably need another
franchise quarterback and thanks for the
time I know you got to go to inside
training camp so on NFL Network's
appreciate it Ian thanks the call all
right thanks for having me rich enjoyed
it I dare right back at you at rap sheet
the one and only in Rappaport NFL Media
Group insider and NFL Network compadre
of mine for more of the rich
and show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app